[Музика]
Привіт усім, мене звуть Кейтлін, і я
запрошую вас на урок англійської мови, щоб
оволодіти нашими презентаційними навичками,
один із найбільших мандрівників
середньовічного світу, сумні подорожі, це робить
вас безмовними,
а потім перетворює вас на оповідача  як
ви розумієте його слова що робить
нас безмовними приголомшливі краєвиди приголомшливі
краєвиди дивовижні краєвиди що ще
те, що позбавило вас мовчання під час однієї з ваших
подорожей згадайте той момент, щоб
картина згасала в очах
опишіть це, розкажіть свою історію, використовуючи
найяскравіші слова, щоб виразити  ви або
запишіть свою промову просто зараз, скористайтеся
диктофоном і запишіть свою промову, знайдіть
хвилинку і прочитайте слово, зробіть це в
кінці уроку, вам знадобиться цей
чувак для запису щойно
[Музика]
давайте дізнаємося кілька порад, як зробити нашу
промови ще більш привабливі для
публіки, тож як ми будемо аналізувати
методи, які використовуються спікерами TED
talks whatta that говорить про впливові
відео від експертів-спікерів на educati  про
бізнес-науку та технологію творчості,
які хотіли б поділитися своїми ідеями, які
варто поширити на нашому уроці, ми
послухаємо вас три доповіді на TED та навчимося
трьом прийомам для отримання навичок презентації.
поради,
щоб ви збиралися послухати одну з
доповідей на TED, тест – подивіться і
дізнайтеся, як оратор почала свою промову, чи
можу я почати, попросивши
підняти руки від аудиторії, скільки з вас, хлопці, відвідували школу Фоулка
школу чи відпустку перед
університетом чи знаю когось, хто підняв
твої руки,
вау, це дуже багато людей,
якби твої руки зробили, якби я задав
те саме запитання аудиторії
американських студентів, я б отримав набагато
менше показів рук  За
даними Північного інституту досліджень та
інновацій та досліджень та освіти,
понад 50% студентів у Норвегії
беруть відпустку перед або під час
навчання в університеті в Америці, за
оцінками,  їх число становить лише 2%, і
знайте, що це лише оцінка в
реальності, коли берете проміжок у році, який
американці називають тим, що відпустка у
школі все ще є настільки нетрадиційною, що
ніхто навіть не намагається відстежити, скільки
учнів насправді роблять це, тож як  вона
почала, вона влаштувала дивовижну річ.
Більше 50% аудиторії, і люди в
цій країні знають, де або взяли
рік перерви, або знали інших, хто це зробив,
тоді як в Америці ця цифра в 25
разів менш дивовижна, тому
перша підказка – почати з  сильне
речення, щоб
привернути увагу аудиторії Техніка номер два, наведіть
приклади, які приклади навести
та як це зробити, прочитайте поради та дізнайтеся
,
що напевно зображення були історіями.
Помітьте, як це працює,
спостерігаючи за розмовою іншого тата, привіт, хлопці,
я  Том з Хорватії за останні
пару років світ був мій
подорожі
автомобілі вантажівки сили мотоцикли човни я
їздив у автобусах поїзди рикші я працював
усі роботи проводжу час з місцевими я
волонтер  eer стала мамою, спробувала речі, які
я ніколи не пробувала раніше, я бачила речі,
які я пам'ятатиму, поки я живу,
і все це майже без грошей
[музика],
то що вона робила,
брат, суперечлива тема, як
подорожувати по світу  майже немає
грошей, це підкріплено яскравими зображеннями
правильно зрозумійте, що техніка номер два, наведіть
приклади, давайте перейдемо до третьої
техніки, яка веде аудиторію в
подорож, який тип подорожі читайте
поради. Кожна подорож має початок,
середину та кінець розмови  мати
його також, ми дізнаємося, як це працює
на одній із доповідей, ми збираємося
послухати доповідь про подорожі та
глобальні зміни, але перш ніж ви послухаєте цю
шестихвилинну доповідь, давайте подумаємо, який
зв’язок між цими двома ідеями,
написаними під час подорожі та  щоб
змінити світ, будь-які зв'язки
зробили б ваші прогнози в порядку, а тепер
послухайте та перевірте, я думаю, що багато з
вас сьогодні в аудиторії люблять подорожувати,
і оскільки ви сьогодні тут, я
збираюся зробити ще один стрибок і сказати, що, коли
ви подорожуєте, ви любите
віддаватись своїм спільнотам
, які відвідуєте, і є
так багато чудових способів зробити це, коли
ви в дорозі  можете здавати кров,
ви можете відвідувати лікарні чи школи, ви
можете навчати, ви можете розпочинати програми, ви
можете будувати будинки, волонтерами, і
крім того, ви можете зробити це, ви можете
змінити підхід до подорожей, ви можете
вирішити, що ви автор подорожей і
що ви будете  змусьте людей турбуватися наступного
разу, коли ви поїдете куди-небудь, чи то
відпустка до Європи чи пішохідна поїздка до
Непалу, швидка прогулянка до Мексики, я
закликаю вас зустріти когось дивовижного
та написати коротку історію про цю
людину, тепер я думаю, що багато хто з
вас думає  ти не хочеш писати,
читай мої твори. Я поганий письменник, але
я тут, щоб сказати тобі, що це має набагато
менше значення, ніж ти думаєш, за останні два
роки редагуючи ці збірки подорожей, я
прочитав понад 600 есе про подорожі, щоб
знайти  65 що я  я б опублікував, і я думаю, що
ви здивуєтеся, дізнавшись,
скільки історій, які його створили, написали
жінки, які ніколи не публікували жодного
слова як редактор, я
шукав чудового написання чудових
оповідань, чудових персонажів, але я  також
шукав великого серця, і, незважаючи на те, що
деякі з історій наприкінці мене прийшли до мене трохи
грубими, історії,
які вплинули на мене, змусили мене піклуватися,
і я твердо вірю, що кожен
тут сьогодні міг би написати історію, яка
б  комусь байдуже, тому я попросив вас
почати з малого, коли наступного разу ви кудись поїдете,
візьміть щоденник, у вас є
щоденники сьогодні, і напишіть історію з чотирьох
абзаців навіть про когось, кого ви зустрічали,
а потім поділіться нею, надішліть її
електронною поштою своїм десяти найближчим друзям або
подайте його на конкурс або в свою
газету,
розмістіть його на Facebook, у вас є Facebook, у
всіх є Facebook, у Facebook зараз більше
користувачів, ніж у Сполучених Штатах,
і вони кажуть, що середній
користувач Facebook має 130  друзі, тож це
означає, що і, ймовірно, багато хто з вас має
більше, ніж це у Facebook, але це
означає, що якби кожен із присутніх
сьогодні написали одну історію та розмістили її на
Facebook, ця історія могла б охопити майже
20 000 людей, але навіть якби вона
досягла одного, це б  все одно важливо,
що ніколи не було простіше записувати наші
історії та знаходити людей, які б їх читали,
але те, що стає рідкісним, — це бажання
зробити це, бажання залучити
зв’язки у наше життя подорожей, а
потім по-справжньому замислитися над значенням,
а потім  щоб поділитися ними з іншими, я
не буду першим розповідати про те,
що ми стаємо більш відокремленим
суспільством, все, що ми хочемо,
можна знайти в Інтернеті, усі наші найактуальніші
запитання можна знайти, відкривши наш
телефон, але якщо ми хочемо  щоб зробити будь-яку реальну
різницю у світі, ми
повинні стати більш пов’язаними, і я не
маю на увазі, що нам потрібно просто прийняти
особисті зустрічі, які трапляються на нашому шляху, я
маю на увазі, що ми повинні шукати  ми повинні
їх ініціювати, ми повинні їх виховувати,
і, можливо, нам доведеться їх виготовити,
є така історія, яку я люблю, про цього
тибетського ченця на ім’я Чак чувак Рінпоче,
який перед своєю смертю
їздив по Сполучених Штатах, навчаючи
медитації, і він ніколи не буде  дозволив своєму
водієві платити за бензин на насосі,
він завжди наполягав на тому, щоб вони разом зайшли
на станцію і
заплатили працівникові особисто, щоб він
міг створити момент
людського зв'язку зараз, якщо ви запитаєте будь-якого
туриста  скажи тобі, так
, це лише частина моєї роботи,
мандрівники зобов'язані зустрічатися з людьми, щоб задавати
питання, щоб звернути увагу, а разом з цим
приходить загострене почуття обізнаності,
підвищене почуття спостережливості та
чудові винагороди, крім хорошої історії, ви
отримуєте багато  багатший досвід, і це
набагато багатший досвід для кожного, коли ви
стаєте свого роду послом своєї
країни,
і люди починають сприймати вас не
просто як звичайного туриста, а як  допитливий
зацікавлений зацікавлений громадянин світу, можливо,
навіть частина їхньої родини
Travel може навчити нас, що весь світ
– це одна велика родина, ми є родичами, і тоді
ви можете взяти цей урок, і ви зможете
навчити інших, ви можете ділитися своїми історіями
та однією за одною тими, хто  прочитавши їх, можливо, ви
почнете усвідомлювати спільність людей
у світі, і вони можуть почати ві
кидати упередження та апатію, тому у с
іті 7 мільярдів людей, і у ко
ного є своя історія, я сподіваюся, що наступного ра
у, коли ви подорожуєте, ви послухаєте її  а
потім я сподіваюся, що ви скажете це, дякую,
тож зв’язок цих двох ідей
безумовно під час подорожі слухайте, як
місцеві жителі пишуть свої історії та діляться
ними зі світом, роблячи це, це
навчить інших, що світ — це
місце, де всі  з нас є родичі, і
завдяки вашим розповідям люди дізнаються
, скільки у нас спільного, і
це допомагає зменшити упередження та апатію
через bujji, і це сила
подорожувати та писати це зараз, давайте f  Зверніть увагу
на структуру цієї промови,
ви послухаєте цю промову ще
раз, і завдання для цього слухання –
подивитися і зловити три її частини,
початок, середину та кінець Я
уявляю, що багато з вас сьогодні в аудиторії
люблять подорожувати  і оскільки ви
сьогодні тут, я зроблю ще один
крок і скажу, що, коли ви подорожуєте, ви
з тих людей, які люблять
повертатися до своїх спільнот, які
ви відвідуєте, і там так багато
чудових  способи зробити це, коли ви
в дорозі, ви можете здавати кров;
ви можете відвідувати лікарні чи школи, ви
можете навчати, ви можете розпочинати програми, ви
можете будувати будинки волонтерами, і
крім того, ви можете зробити це, ви можете
змінити підхід до подорожей, які ви можете
вирішіть, як автор подорожей ере, і що
ви змусите людей хвилюватися, коли наступного разу
ви поїдете куди-небудь, чи то відпустка
до Європи чи пішохідна подорож до Непалу,
швидка прогулянка до Мексики. Я закликаю вас
зустріти когось дивовижного та написати коротку
історію про це.  синку, тепер я думаю,
що багато хто з вас думає, що ви не
хочете писати, читайте мої записи. Я поганий
письменник, але я тут, щоб сказати вам, що це
має набагато менше значення, ніж ви думаєте за
останні два роки, редагуючи ці
збірки подорожей  Я прочитав понад 600
есе про подорожі, щоб знайти 65, які
опублікуватиму, і я думаю, що ви здивуєтеся
, дізнавшись, скільки історій,
які його створили, написали жінки, які
ніколи не публікували жодного слова, звичайно,
як редактор.  Я шукав
чудового написання чудових оповідань, чудових
персонажів, але я також шукав
великого серця, і хоча деякі
історії врешті-решт прийшли до мене трохи грубими
, історії, які вийшли
на сцену, змусили мене піклуватися, і я
Я твердо
вірю, що кожен тут сьогодні міг би
написати історію, яка змусить когось
турбуватися, тому я попросив вас почати з малого, коли
наступного разу ви поїдете кудись, принесіть
щоденник, у вас сьогодні є щоденники, і
напишіть історію з чотирьох абзаців навіть про
когось, кого ви зустріли, а потім sh  надішліть
це електронною поштою вашим 10 найближчим
друзям чи подайте його на конкурс чи до
вашої газети, розмістіть це на Facebook, у
вас є Facebook, у всіх є
Facebook, у Facebook зараз більше користувачів,
ніж у Сполучених Штатах, і
вони кажуть, що  Середній користувач Facebook
має 130 друзів, тож це означає, що і,
ймовірно, у багатьох із вас більше, ніж
у Facebook, але це означає, що якби
кожен із присутніх сьогодні написав одну
історію та розмістив її на Facebook, ця історія
могла б охопити майже 20 000 людей, але
навіть якщо вона  щойно досягнуто одного,
все одно було б важливо, що ніколи не було
простіше записувати наші історії та
знаходити людей, які б їх читали, але те, що
стає рідкісним, це бажання зробити
це, бажання запросити зв’язки
у наше життя подорожей, а потім по-справжньому
замислитися  про значення, а потім поділитися
ними з іншими, я не буду першим, хто
розповідатиме про те, що ми
стаємо більш відокремленим суспільством,
усе, що ми хочемо, можна знайти в Інтернеті
усі наші найактуальніші запитання
можна знайти, відкривши наш телефон, але якщо ми
хочемо щось змінити
в світі, нам потрібно бути більш
пов’язаними, і я не маю на увазі, що нам
потрібно просто приймати особисті зустрічі,
які відбуваються  по-нашому, я маю на увазі, що ми повинні
їх шукати, ми повинні ініціювати їх,
ми повинні їх виховувати, і, можливо, нам доведеться
їх виготовити, є така історія, яку я
люблю, про цього тибетського
ченця на ім'я Чак чувак Рінпоче, який до своєї смерті
він подорожував
навколо Сполучених Штатів навчав
медитації, і він ніколи не дозволяв своєму
водієві платити за бензин на насосі,
він завжди наполягав, щоб вони разом зайшли
на станцію і заплатили
супроводжувальному особисто, щоб він міг
створити можливість моменту
людського зв'язку  Тепер, якщо ви запитаєте будь-кого з
авторів подорожей, вони вам скажуть, так
, це лише частина моєї роботи.
усвідомлення підвищене відчуття
спостережливості та чудові винагороди на
додаток до гарної історії, ви отримуєте набагато
багатший досвід, і це набагато багатший
досвід для кожного, ви стаєте свого
роду послом своєї країни, і
люди починають дивитися на вас не просто як на
середнього  турист, але як зацікавлений
зацікавлений громадянин світу, можливо, навіть
частина їхньої сімейної подорожі може навчити нас,
що весь світ – це одна велика родина,
ми є родичами, і тоді ви можете взяти цей
урок і навчити інших, ви можете
поділитися своїми історіями та одним  за одним, ті,
хто їх читає, можуть почати визнавати
спільність людей у світі, і во
и можуть почати відкидати упередження та ап
тію, тому у світі є сім мільярдів людей, і у
кожного є своя історія, я сп
діваюся, що наступного разу, коли ви подорожуєте, ви.
.  Я послухаю один, а потім, сподіваюся,
ви скажете його, дякую,
тож ви зрозуміли, що доповідач сказав
на початку, що під час подорожі
віддайте спільноті, яку ви
відвідуєте, як пожертвувати б  lood
освіта починаючи деякі програми
писати історії місцевих жителів
посередині це йшлося про саму історію
, розмір значення, ціль, і в
заключній частині я отримав повідомлення, що у світі є сім
мільярдів людей, і кожен має
свою історію, слухаючи їх історії.
ними та поділіться з іншими, зробивши це,
ви зробите різницю у
світі
. Ідея, яку варто поширити, погодьтеся, тому
сьогодні ми навчимося трьом навичкам презентації.
аудиторія під час подорожі візьміть
до уваги структуру вашої
розмови на той час, щоб повернутися до
запису, який ви зробили на початку
нашого уроку, послухайте його та дізнайтеся, які
прийоми ви використовували та покращіть його ми
пишемо це робимо його чернеткою, а потім записуємо
вас  знову тому, що ваше домашнє завдання – записати
свою покращену історію на тему, а потім
опублікуйте її у своєму дописі в Instagram та
позначте TED talks Ukraine, в якій будуть переможці
був запрошений на конференцію студентів,
організовану National
Geographic Learning Ukraine, тож для
нас настав час і
позначити, що наш урок переможний,
тому слідкуйте за оновленнями та до скорої зустрічі
[Музика]
ви